hi good evening and welcome to this
overview of scrutiny committee meeting
on thursday the 15th of october 2020
my name is councillor michael helm and i
am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
covid19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your microphones remain muted
and your video feed off
when not addressing the committee this
will reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during this
during each item please use the chat
function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
burner will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function should not be used
for questions or any other purpose
please do not use the raise hand
function as this is not available on all
members devices
when speaking and referring to agenda
papers please ensure you reference the
page and paragraph number
and last if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave the meeting
now if i may i will ask officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
ms hughes
hi i'm cheryl hughes i'm the program's
performance and governance manager
thank you berna good evening members
i'm bernie casey clark to the meeting
this evening thank you
have we any other officers present
no chairman thank you very much uh
[Music]
can you carry out a roll call please
yes chairman members i will call your
name in alphabetical order
starting with councillor bell i'm here
good evening everybody thank you
councillor fleming
hi bernard present thank you councillor
helm
president i think councillor morley
counselor morley
okay counselor none
yes i'm here berna uh good evening
everyone
good evening council casters
uh good evening burner present thank you
councillor stamp
uh good evening uh burner members i'm
present
thank you thank you members this counts
i thought custom morty was in the
meeting
earlier uh just before the meeting
anyway
okay thank you members thank you
chairman apologies for absence please
yes we've received apologies for absence
from councillors duik and herd
and councillor stamp is substituting for
councillor howard this evening
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh minutes of the fifth of march 2020
found on pages five to eight page
five page six
page seven page eight
your grade agreed
no no or anything right we'll move on
then
um message sherman yeah i'd just like to
raise a couple of points
um if i may yes um just in relation
to um information that page
it's uh a couple of uh issues um
mr chairman just on reports on park and
ride i think
that might be page one we i haven't
received such a report
and uh just to comment that we have only
just
received the briefing note regarding
capital i just wanted to comment on
timeliness of information mr chairman
thank you
yes right thank you very much for that
uh
all in agreed public participation
i can advise that we have not received
any submissions from
from members of the public declarations
of interest
please berna anyone got declaration of
interest
no no
we'll move on to committee operating
protocol and working practices
ms hughes please
thank you um so good evening members
um appendix a for this report found on
pages 11 and 12 of your pack
provides a suggested committee protocol
for adoption
this builds on training provided to the
committee last year and discussions
around
this as well as a briefing note that was
supplied at that time
which has been referenced as appendix b
which is on page 15.
the aim is to set clear detailed ways of
working
and agreed standards for defining and
progressing items for overview and
scrutiny
a recent corporate governance audit has
picked up on a lack of detail
and direction of overview and scrutiny
and recommended
better clarity and accompanying training
and so this aims to address that
the corporate governance working group
also reviewed the committee
and whether it was required as part of a
wider review
um on the committee structure that was
implemented in 2019
and they recommended continuation but
also considered it important to be clear
in the remit of this committee
because we don't have the cabinet system
typically associated with overview and
scrutiny
additionally on page 13 of appendix a
there's a suggested terms of reference
for the working group established at the
committee
which currently has the four listed
members appointed to it
you will see an agenda item seven an
intention to use this working group as a
mechanism to review the detail of items
and recommend actions and additions to
the work plan going forwards
a recommendation in this committee
report is for the working group to sit
ahead of committee meetings to be able
to do that
in summary the intention of this report
and recommendations are to establish
a good foundation and clear direction
for the committee
so that when it's reconstituted at the
statutory annual meeting in november
the 10 members appointed have a clear
direction
for how they confirm their work plan and
work going forwards
thank you if any member wishes to second
that motion please turn on your video
unlock your microphone and state your
name now please
anybody i'll second that
chairman thank you councillor stan
uh thank you i now invite members to
make any comments on the report please
thank you um mr chairman i just want
training we received did i miss
something
i don't recall any uh scrutiny training
for the committee
and actually that was something i really
wanted to talk about
because i think it's absolutely vital
that
um that committee members receive
appropriate training
so i do apologize if i've had a senior
moment and missed that but i don't
recall receiving any
thank you i think that's probably to
come isn't it misuse
so we have additional training lined up
um but i was referring to the briefing
sessions and briefing notes provided by
um mr jennings um previously late last
year
yeah i remember
so and notes rather than a training
session to clarify
yeah through the chat yes thank you
anybody else wants to uh speak about
this chairman councillor siddhl and
counselor nun
pass the signal please
thank you chairman i am with councillor
bell on this
we did not have any training this
committee has never had any training
and in terms of what happened in
the yeah our first year in terms of
uh getting us equipped to run this cat
this committee effectively
it is really quite shocking in terms of
what what went on
uh i had to do a huge amount of research
a hearing about
reading up myself in terms of what an
overview and security committee does
i think last year
there was still confusion about what an
overview and scrutiny does
i think it's great that we have this
clarity i think it's great that we have
you know the working group that's going
to be set up that was that was something
that i put forward
we didn't really have any training it
was about a half an hour chat
by mr jennings who went through
what an overview and security committee
could do
um and obviously we talked about him in
terms of the terms of reference
for the working group so it's really
really important
after the statutory annual that whoever
comes on this committee
is given proper training and education
about how a overview and scrutiny
committee works
a lot of the times we've been
floundering trying to
to put forward ideas put forward
scrutiny items
and then we get from officers well
that's not really a scrutiny item that's
not really something that we
that scrutiny so it's good that we have
this clarity
now in terms of the email that uh
mr hughes sent to vanessa
about the uh the scrutiny of the
transformation program
that is not true what's been put in that
that email i asked last year for reports
on the transformation program and i
asked for the reports about what
happened at the initial stage of the the
transformation
program i was not provided
with any reports i spoke to mr dodson
about that early in the year and because
of covid
i said well you've got lots of other
things that you need to focus upon
so therefore it's not a priority
however ensuring that someone looks at
in after november looks at that
transformation program
and how the transformation was set up
because that is where my most of my
concerns were
that is a an item that needs to be
scrutinized
and something that we can do in terms of
the principles about lessons learned
about what went on at that particular
point so
i i yeah that the reason why that didn't
move forward is because i wasn't given
any information
so yeah that really is something that
that yeah when the working group comes
together whether it's something that i
need to feel that forming or someone
else does
yeah then it is something that that does
need to happen
so yes it's great but we do need
someone to come in and train
individuals who are going to be sitting
on this committee after november
okay thank you very much
anybody else vanessa
i agreed with absolutely everything
counselor single says mr chairman
is next chairman
uh thank you berna thank you chairman um
i'd like to thank cheryl hughes for the
paper
uh and for the clarity of the paper
cheryl
uh albeit that maybe it's just me being
overly sensitive but it does contain
a bit of a ticking off for members in
places
uh but thank you very much for putting
it together
i know we haven't got a cabinet system
and i hope that maldon district council
never does have a cabinet system
but given maldon district council's
recent history
i think the over overview and scrutiny
committee
is an essential part of our of our
governance
and i would urge members of this
committee
and across the wider council to include
items to be considered by this committee
because
it always seems to me to be very thin
in terms of its agenda and obviously
it's got to be relevant we need to
include relevant things
but let's make use of ons otherwise
you know the danger is we'll lose it
thank you very much chairman
thank you very much i'm just going to
switch the lights on for a minute
that's better if i put my head in the
light you'll be all right
um
do you wish to agree this by scent uh
chairman sorry cancer
stamp would like to okay yeah
thank you i didn't think it had gone
through bernie now it's gone through
twice
across the top yeah it's like an omnibus
you don't get any and then you get two
at once
uh sorry sorry chairman what did you do
what number bust you on then
oh i don't know number nine um as
counselor
heard asked me just to mention something
and i hope i'm allowed to say it
i don't know if it's in the right place
but he actually said um is there any
chance that this committee
in its new form would be able to look at
things for example
and this is the example he gave me was
pre-determination
you know like what went to the jsc and
the way that was handled
he was very keen that his committee
if it was brought by a member could
actually look at
how that committee at that stage didn't
didn't add to it dear to its terms of
reference
chairman and counselor heard actually
asked me to specifically
he wanted to know the process behind it
and he thought it would be
excellent clarity for the members on
this group and even jsc
or even members of the council or the
committees
that they understand certain procedures
fully
um i know um miss hughes um that it is
in
uh the constitution or some of it is
when when
members or chairman don't follow it our
officers
and we do need to look at why they're
not following it and i think it's only
fair that we give an explanation
of why they're not being followed is
that okay chairman is all right
just gotta fill in the form and send it
in to the working group
yeah i i actually agreed to this i've
read this i think this is an excellent
paper
same as councillor none i've put a
little bit of question marks on some
thinking it
i'm back at school and i was expecting a
bit of a red pen and a bit of marker
to tell me off but other than that i
think it's an excellent paper and i also
thank uh
ms hughes thank you okay
anyone else uh no chairman do you wish
to agree by sent
agreed i
mechanism for submitting an overview and
scrutiny
item um cheryl would you like
news would you like to carry on with
that please yep so um thank you members
so this second report provided gives a
suggested approach
building on previous breast uh
conversations and best practice
around the mechanism for bringing
forwards and managing overview and
scrutiny items
to their conclusion um it's the
intention that this process would be
underpinned with officer support
and through the established committee
working group
and a step-by-step framework is outlined
at appendix a
on page 19 of your pack there's a
proposal that any member could submit a
suggestion for a scrutiny item
and then a robust review as to whether
this is a valid
item for the committee work plan would
take place
so just to take you um step by step i'm
going to load the diagram
hopefully and so this is the
this is the item that is um
appendix
okay so this is the program
yeah um so the idea is that any member
of molden district
council would be able to submit a
request for overview and scrutiny to
review an item
and but the review for whether or not
this would be taken forward
or suggested to be taken forward would
happen within that working group
and the working group would have a quite
set criteria
um and obviously an officer working with
them and training provided
to be able to kind of establish whether
that was valid
um within the working group meeting
if they did deem it to be an item to put
forwards the idea is that they would
also
scope so identify a potential lead
officer
identify potentially who was involved
and a potential timetable
and a scrutiny outcome associated with
that item
and then that would all come back as a
proposed draft work plan
to the committee meetings and then the
committee meetings would be about
reviewing that and
either adopting or not um into the work
plan
those items so the basis of that and
obviously
um other work plan items that would have
already been identified
the scrutiny work would be undertaken
and the project would take place
and then the report associated with that
item
would come back to the committee meeting
and at the committee meeting the
committee would review the report
and either agree or challenge
conclusions that
the report comes to and it might make
recommendations to council
um off the back of what comes out of the
report as well
so that's uh we've kind of um
outlined that as the process to try and
make the links to other areas
and thank you members um and just
one last point to make is that um to
support the
suggested process um an appendix b
on page 21 of your pack has provided an
outline of the form so that would be the
form that would start off the process
just to show the idea of what it would
capture and that's the member of you
and hopefully adoption thank you
thank you very much if any member wishes
to second the motion
please turn on your video and under your
microphone
and also state your name now please
oh it's a bit of a competition
i will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
bernie can you let me know please
counselor nun chairman
yes again thank you very much to cheryl
for
doing this and making it all so clear
[Music]
i mean it's a bit local government
cheryl but then we are aren't we so uh
if i know in the diagram uh
item two uh where the working group is
considering the submission um
should that not also have something that
says
that feedback is given to the counsellor
that's made the submission
because if it doesn't progress i think
the counselor has a right to be told
that and to be
and and have an explanation as to why
it's
not progressed i mean that lends itself
more to a
a flow diagram than a circular
arrangement like that but i
hopefully i've made myself clear thank
you
anybody else yes chairman and
sorry that was quite that was a question
that was a question sorry
yeah yep so absolutely we can include
that
the intention was that we would be
communicating with the members that put
the form in um but yet we can include
that in the process
thank you thank you very much chair
thank you cheryl sorry i'll cut you off
there sorry about that
uh who else counselors bell
none and sorry counselors bell siddl and
stamp would like to speak german
first um yes really just briefly to uh
echo what counselor nun said and thank
um
the officer for for this i think it
brings some much needed structure
to um overview and scrutiny and uh
yeah i think it's it's very positive
thank you thanks council
council
thank you chairman uh yeah i was gonna
add
uh yeah to this yeah i think this is
excellent gerald and uh it's it's
fantastic work and giving a fantastic
structure to the process
uh like counselor nun i i think that
yeah it does need to be
more of a flow diagram rather than a
circular
because uh the other thing that i can
see is that
it probably could go back at each of the
stages so perhaps
stage three could go back to stage two
at stage four and go back to so that
there could be something in terms of
yeah where it gets to a particular point
and like a feasibility
study or something like when the the
scoping's done
it could be that the the officer then
says well actually
this isn't is it as expected or
or it could go back to the working group
for more questions
the other thing that might be useful in
terms
of the uh the committee
is there's only four people on the
working group
does the committee get to see the things
that the working group
decides isn't going forward as a
scrutiny item so would there be
reporting of
you know a member has raised this but we
don't think it is a scrutiny item so
that
so there is that completeness to to the
process
um and yeah it in terms of the scrutiny
under undertaking again
it's yeah it's to me it's
uh it's not necessary a step by step it
could be a step and then a step back
so just you know fine-tuning
how that process might work i know where
this
child's got a view on that cheryl
yeah so i take your point this is kind
of an ideal world process where we did
something in the project ran right
end to end um so yeah there would be
remit for that
um and the way i saw it with your um
point about reporting
is that actually there would be a a
gender item that would be
a report of the working group so they
could report on recommendations for
items for um additions to the work
plan but also just what happened in the
last meeting and
items that were deemed unnecessary as
well okay that's excellent
thank you councillor stamp
i believe thank you chairman um yes can
i ask the officer
or you chairman um it says political
balance
uh applies to this committee uh does it
apply to the working group
and if it does it how could we actually
change that because i think this commit
is as important as all the rest
obviously under grc
and i'm very keen that is actually
shared out equally
or for you know 2-1 and whatever
whatever it is with the parties when it
comes to the statutory annual
is there any way we could do that um
chairman through your chairman to um
miss hughes well it is equal at the
moment
it is chairman but i'd like to future
proof it is what i've heard said a few
times around council meetings so
if you don't mind can miss you can you
give us
if the committee requested it we could
add it in the terms of reference for
that working group
um at the moment it's not a you know
it's just whoever's appointed to that
working group
so thank you chairman and would that
happen most probably at the first
committee meeting
because what bothers me is if there is a
massive change for some reason
and you have four people on the working
group i'm really keen that the four
people on the working group
are balanced so two and two or one from
non-alliance or whatever
i think we've got to be inclusive from
now on carter
the committee will make up their mind
who who's on that working group isn't
that right cheryl
yes there you are did that
suffice no well not really because i'm
looking to most probably try and change
that
so how how would we change it so it was
political it was sort of fair
they they've appreciated the motion to
cancel like what we've done in the past
um so the previous agenda item we've
just approved those
um working group um terms of reference
yes so it'll be an amendment to those
um it's just that
you know what i'm getting at though yeah
i do they'll be speaking clumsily
through you chairman
but i'm very i'm very keen that it is
actually done properly
it doesn't matter it's maybe for a
different day i'll i'll read it and i'll
i'll take it back to you or to the
committee
thank you thank you very much mrs
stem anybody else chairman cancer
fleming kessler fleming
please thank you chairman um yeah i just
wanted to comment
uh that this does bring much needed
structure
uh i think the form is a great idea and
then
following on from councillor stamps
comments about the working group
i actually agree with councillor trump
it should be
politically balanced um at the moment
it's not politically balanced
um anyway but cheryl i understand you
were saying that we
we couldn't sort of revisit that at this
stage is that right
sorry it's just um uh
because we've just approved the working
group um
terms of reference i think it would
probably be better to tidy that up as
the
on the next committee meeting yeah yeah
good thank you so
much no chairman
all right uh
where are we now if any member wishes to
second that motion oh i've done that
yes if you just put the recommendations
to the committee
i've got to get the next page now
it's on page four i've got it
move to the recommendation can we uh do
this by scent please
agreed agreed
any items the business that the chairman
decides are urgent
uh only one thank you very much for
putting up with me all this time
i really appreciate your
input and everything else and i wish the
my successor every luck
thank you and now close the meeting
at 18
28. thank you thank you
thank you thank you